hätte man anfangen 2013 nur 100 euro in
bitcoin investiert wären die sie heute
über 100.000 euro wert hätte man 1000
euro investiert wir haben jetzt sogar
millionär
bitcoin war die erste und ist die
wertvollste crypto währung und ähnlich
wie bei aktien kann man zu einem
günstigen zeitpunkt viel davon einkaufen
und dann an einem hochpunkt viel teurer
mit prophet wieder verkaufen und das
theoretisch ohne viel arbeit von überall
auf der welt aus und egal ob vom laptop
vom pc oder am smartphone viele denken
aber wahrscheinlich zu recht bitcoin
kann sich ja wohl schlecht nochmal für
10.000 fach im gegensatz zu uns so
genannte old konz sind wie der name
schon sagt alternativen zur bekannten
crypto währungen wie bitcoin und
theorien die bekanntesten beispiele
darunter sind stars köln oder der shiba
inu freund der sich in unter einem jahr
50.000 fach hat 100 euro investiert ende
2020 werden also heute fünf millionen
euro wert das ganze ist mehr glück als
verstand müsste man zumindest meinen
denn es gibt genug angeblich experten
die behaupten es gibt methoden und
strategien um herauszufinden welche art
von der nächste patch chronist und der
videos sind zumindest ein klick und nike
zahlen zufolge sogar vertrauenswert aber
wie genau soll das jetzt gehen wie genau
von wem und auf welchen märkten kauft
man überhaupt diese holt kunst diese
woche werde ich ein experiment machen
mit insgesamt 1000 euro mit der hälfte
werde ich mit einer vielversprechenden
methode unentdeckte heute coins
aufspüren und auf deren anstieg warten
und mit den anderen 500 euro werde ich
als bekannt bitcoins handeln denn auch
dort gibt es tricks und systeme die
versprechen den kurs berechenbar und
damit zu einer reinen gold quelle zu
machen werden nicht htg funktionieren
und sich meinen 1000 euro investment
vervielfachen oder werde ich trotzdem
geld verlieren vielleicht sogar alles
wir finden es raus dieses video wird von
acer unterstützt deren produkte habt ihr
vielleicht schon in meinen letzten
gewissen acts wie zum beispiel den
monitor der konzept die cp 3 serie oder
auch das konzept die fünf pro notebook
alle produkte vom konzept die sind extra
für kreativschaffende ausgelegt der
monitor zum beispiel ein pantone
validiertes 4k ultra hd display mit
einer super farbgenauigkeit auf
instagram für sich nächste woche auch
genau diesen monat war also schaute
unbedingt mal vorbei ansonsten gibt es
noch mehr infos in der video
beschreibung was ihr bestimmt alle
wissen ist dass man bitkom durch das
bitcoin mining am pc quasi herstellen
kann wie ich es in diesem video mal
ausprobiert habe diesmal will ich aber
nur handeln ähnlich wie ich es in dem
wir schon mal gemacht habe deswegen die
frage wie kommt man überhaupt skripte
währungen vor allem an old coins wenn
man sich nicht selber meint warum steigt
oder fällt eigentlich der kurs überhaupt
die ganze zeit und wie kann man damit
geld verdienen der einfachste weg um
kunst zu bekommen ist es geld bei einem
so genannten krebse broker einzuzahlen
das sind meistens apps oder websites wo
man zb euro gegen eine clubtour währung
wie zum beispiel bitcoin tauschen kanten
der broker dient hierbei als vermittler
zwischen oft tausenden nutzern die alle
zum beispiel euro in bitcoin oder
bitcoin in euro tauschen wollen und
somit indirekt miteinander handeln ohne
kontakt miteinander zu haben zum
verständnis kann man sich mal folgendes
modell vorstellen mit dem neuen fiktiven
tom reach der noch sehr unbekannt ist
und dadurch nur ein bis zweimal pro tag
ge und verkauft wird immer wenn jetzt
einen jemand so einen tollen loswerden
will werden wir ihn einfach mal thomas
er stellte eine art sofort kaufangebot
über ebay obwohl noch gestern tom reach
für nur 40.000 euro pro stück den
besitzer gewechselt haben versucht
thomas sein glück und verlangt nun
50.000 es findet sich sofort eine
käuferin nennen wir sie charlotte die
denkt der tolerieren wird sogar noch
weiter steigen durch diesen kauf ist der
thommy konkurs nun von gestern noch
40.000 auf heute 50.000 euro gestiegen
am tag darauf freut sich alex lange wie
regatta noricum besitzer dass ein
investment nun auch mehr wert ist und
nimmt diese preissteigerung zum anlass
einen tollen mit gewinn zu verkaufen er
versucht ebenfalls sein glück und
erstellt ein angebot für 60.000 euro
deutlich über dem kurs von gestern
findet aber keinen käufer er senkt den
preis also und zwar so lange bis er
selbst bei 50.000 euro keinen käufer
findet der glaubt dass der thommy von
über 50.000 euro steigen kann und er
stellt ein neues angebot für nur 45.000
euro mit dem er immer noch zufrieden
wäre nun findet sich direkt ein käufer
und damit ist der kurs von 50.000 euro
auf 45.000 euro gefallen das ist
natürlich nur grob vereinfacht und
passiert beim bitcoin hunderte male pro
minute bei meinen recherchen stoße ich
also nicht nur auf strategien mit denen
man diese kursschwankungen beim bitcoin
ausnutzen kann zu denen wir später
kommen sondern auch auf eine besonders
spannende methode um old course zu
entdecken die der nächste bitcoin werden
könnten
ich beginne jetzt direkt mit der methode
kleine noch komplett neue coins mit viel
luft nach oben aufzuspüren und zu
schauen ob die nahe zukunft irgendwelche
events oder aktionen geplant sind durch
die das nach oben schießen könnte auf
der seite sieht man jetzt alle möglichen
crypto währungen hier nach größe
sortiert also bitcoin ganz oben dann
hilft ihm jetzt kann man aber auch
einfach nach neu sortieren dann werden
die neuesten oben angezeigt zum beispiel
der coin wurde erst vor einer stunde
gemacht denn da sind natürlich auch dass
es ganz viele trittbrettfahrer gibt wie
zum beispiel diese schipany oder granny
china also ganz viele leute wollen
einfach hier von einem hype profitieren
und aufspringen ob das ist die beste
strategie ist da einfach mitzumachen
weil sie nicht was ich nicht aussparen
sein könnte es der crown hier der jetzt
insgesamt 40.000 dollar investiert hat
er könnte man jetzt schon mit 1000 euro
extra den kurs richtig nach oben bewegen
werden dass bei bitcoin ja praktisch
gesehen nicht ins gewicht weil schieber
mit lamas ob spartacus ich wollte mir
jetzt mal alle anschaue und einzelnen
recherchiert welche davon vielleicht
zukunft hat gehe ich jetzt noch mal auf
andere seite die mir bei vielen
verschiedenen coins irgendwelche events
und ausstehenden updates von den
technischen hintergrund und so die mir
das alles anzeigt und da etwas
spannendes dabei ist und das ja scheint
schon echt cool abzugehen 17 uhr uci das
ist heute um 18 uhr und 90 prozent der
leute also fast 3000 sagen das ist
saugeil das einkaufen wo kriege ich denn
jetzt ein auto have said works online
fast so finde ich mich ein bisschen haut
bei calden die website hier kalt es ist
kalt an obey smartchain die central
processing plattform youtube der ns
euthanasie anlegt ich bin überzeugt also
um diese sogenannten old course zu
handeln muss sich auf eine gold coin
börse und da hab ich jetzt hier mal die
beiden bekanntesten im vergleich um tian
beide nur 3,2 sterne von 5 fasst jetzt
nicht so vertrauenserweckend wirkt
tatsächlich auszahlung gebühren 9 euro
anderen sind sogar 30 euro gerechnet
dass der
inszenierten market maker ein system das
auf nutzer finanziert und
ist eine crypto börse von den cayman
islands das kind auch gut ja das ist für
mich deutlich unkomplizierter ausland
jetzt muss ich natürlich geld einzahlen
die muss ich auch erstmal auf eine
andere krippe die börse kaufen mal 600
dollar in die kasse abgelehnt okay
das wird schon wieder abgelehnt wieso
denn also meine normale kreditkarte
darauf jetzt nicht so viel lust ich
probier's einfach mal eine andere wenn
man noch mal 500 dollar harz geklappt
jetzt muss ich die nur noch von hier von
cryptic punkt com auf diesen dubiosen
bit markt bringen zu unter für scanning
workout so und jetzt schickt
ich habe natürlich wieder große
erfahrungen darin ob das was ich da
mache jetzt sinn macht noch großes
vertrauen darin dass sich damit erfolg
habe alles was ich tue ist stumpf den
plan folgen und abwarten was passiert
okay ich habe jetzt einfach zwei stunden
später noch mal drauf geschaut und nicht
nur sieht es die seite jetzt irgendwie
viel cooler aus als vorher keine ahnung
wieso aber wenn ich hier darauf geht
dann sehe ich auch die 570 us-dollar
sind drauf und jetzt kann ich mir
hoffentlich dieses calvins polen
ja da ist es ja ok vor drei wochen hat
sich das einfach an einem tag
vervierfacht gut ich kann mir zum einen
einfach mal für 100 dollar oder placed
okay und nun heißt abwarten ob sie unser
investment ausgezahlt hat neben der
gefahr dass solche kleinen coins
zwischen der ganzen konkurrenz einfach
in der bedeutungslosigkeit versinken
gibt es aber auch noch das risiko
schlichtweg auf einen betrug
reinzufeiern erst kürzlich haben anleger
mit einem queue basierend auf der serie
street game 2,1 millionen dollar
verloren
bei solchen sogenannten rag puls bei dem
einen der buchstäbliche teppich unter
den füßen weggezogen wird wie hier sind
die betrüger gleichzeitig auch die
ersteller des cons und halten einen
großteil ihrer eigenen währung einfach
selbst sobald der konsum ihm wurde und
der wert stieg verkauften die betrüger
schlagartig ihre anteile und der preis
fiel in wenigen sekunden von zwei dollar
85 auf 0,08 cent gab derweil wie verdi
coins vorher untersucht und nicht
einfach blind kauft sollte aber nicht
auf solche masche hereinfallen mal
schauen ob mir das gelingt mehrere
stunden sind vergangen das ist eine
coole event um 18 uhr ist vorbei ich
weiß man wie sich das entwickelt hat
okay ist gestiegen gekauft haben 0,25
jetzt ist gerade mal zwei jahre ist es
nicht viel gestiegen okay das nehme man
fast zwölf prozent ich hab ihm
ausgerechnet ich habe 101 dollar 50
investiert das ist jetzt 112 euro 70
werte ging es um ordentlich hoch habe
ich um 18 uhr wo ihr eigentlich irgend
was geplant war er kenne ich eigentlich
nichts besonders verkauf jetzt direkt
mal den profit nämlich mit und jetzt
muss natürlich auch schon direkt nach
seiner nächsten untersuchen nächste
größere ist was bei conny cx da soll
übermorgen was passieren hier sehe ich
das bei einem truck ein quasi übermorgen
was passiert was genau ist weiß ich
nicht und 80 prozent der leute ja denken
aber das ist ein zeichen für profit und
da setzt kürzlich mega hunde gegangen
ist gibt es ein logo das geht noch
weiter nach unten als es nicht okay
strafen diesmal für 230 dollar
zusätzlich habe ich noch zwei weitere
coins nach demselben schema gekauft und
somit meine 500 euro auf der old course
börse fürs erste ausgeschöpft und so
wenige menschen handeln gerade mit
diesem können das ist super schwierig
ist da überhaupt ranzukommen war wird
man sieht hier quasi im gleichen minute
den ganzen tag für den verkäufer
durchgehen und ich glaube die hälfte
davon bin ich und die leute die jetzt
den kaufen treiben den kurs nach oben
weil ich habe jetzt hier für 00 1 57
eine bestellung aber die kirche hat
nicht weil irgendeiner 00 158 meter
schon fast das so zu sehen wie man
selber diesen kurs behandlungsraum
schild jetzt mega crash gespannt aber
auch ich nie wieder mit profit rausgehen
können während wir hier warten widme ich
mich dem bekanntesten bitcoin dessen
kurs ist so heißt es jedenfalls viel
berechenbarer und mit methoden der
trendanalyse soll man ihn oft
vorhersagen können und das probiere
jetzt für die straße gehe ich jetzt
verfolgen werde drei sogenannte
indikatoren das sind diese lustigen
bunten linien hier nennen sich
gleitender durchschnitt werde ich jetzt
nicht genau darauf eingehen wenn er kurz
gerade allgemeine aufwärtstrend ist was
man an diesen drei linien scheinbar
kennt und der kurs dann leicht nach
unten wieder geht die blaue linie durch
bericht aber nicht so tief geht dass die
rote linie durchprobiert und danach
wieder über die blaue linie drüber geht
dann soll man da einsteigen laut
strategie genauso wichtig wie die
richtige einstieg ist aber auch der
richtige ausstieg und das machen wir in
dem fall mit einer automatischen stop
loss grenze automatisch verkauft wird
und zwar auf der höhe vom letzten
tiefpunkt geben um seine verluste zu
minimieren und auch nach oben hin also
wenn der kurs steigt gibt es auch eine
grenze wo das automatisch wieder beendet
wird um eben natürlicher zu bringen und
zwar seit man die so dass der
potenzielle gewinn 15 mal höher ist als
der potenzielle verlust kriegen super
kompliziert man schauen habe ich dann im
richtigen moment erwischt so und hier
passiert jetzt genau das was ich gerade
angesprochen haben aufwärtstrend ist ein
kursbuch linien gekommen und kommen
jetzt hoffentlich wieder über die
blauelinie ist noch nicht ganz durch
ok jetzt ist durch das öffnen der
position mit einem stop loss unter dem
letzten tief verhältnis eins zu fünf ich
würde sagen ich in das thema 100 euro
das risiko relativ klein und jetzt
abwarten was passiert
[Musik]
ja gut das sieht jetzt doch gar nicht so
gut aus denn der sitzt quasi fast beim
stop loss wenn ihr jetzt da runter geht
und sind wir raus nochmal verlust
gemacht ja und da sind wir raus also wir
sind jetzt zum glück hier schon raus
aber wir gehen jetzt definitiv aber das
kann uns egal sein weil wir haben ja
unser risiko vermieden schade direkt
darauf bietet sich eine nächste chance
und ich danke erneut einen nach
strategie diesmal direkt mit 400 dollar
und ich warte und warte und hängen
nebenbei auch social media herum weg
gehen kann ich ja nicht da ich denn
nicht ein auge auf den kurs werfen muss
und siehe da diesmal war es ein erfolg
0,3 prozent gewinn also ein dollar 20
abzüglich handelsgebühren ärgerlich ist
dass der kurs hinterher noch deutlich
höher steigt aber das ist okay ich
versuche trotzdem genau nach plan
vorzugehen und nicht emotional oder
gierig zu werden die tage vergehen und
meine aktion werden routinierter
nebenbei laufen aber natürlich noch die
olt coins gab es hier jetzt eine
verzweigte sogar verdreifachung wie
erhofft die events also alle events der
coins der auf die wir gehofft haben sind
mittlerweile durch grund verkaufe ich
die ganzen konzerts erstmal
gewinnbringend schauen wir mal was
passiert ist ich sehe schon ziemlich
viel grün was cool ist habe ich genau
hier an der stelle an gekauft das ging
dann ordentlich nach oben ist aber jetzt
auch wieder gerade eben erst ordentlich
nach unten gefallen nichts dass das
trotzdem wäre nach 2,4 prozent im plus
noch mal ein gutes stück besser sei es
dann mit beach ein haus gekauft ist
aktuell deutlich höher aber alle
wildesten saß bei diesen krokauer aus
der ist einmal von 0 23 auf 0 40 euro
geschossen das ist für mich über 50
prozent gewinn was bleibt ist hier hatte
ich allerdings relativ wenig investieren
das meist gar nicht eigentlich ein cover
und waging investiert also vielleicht
ein bisschen aufs falsche pferd gesetzt
aber weiß man ja nie und einfach was
interessen hier nochmal der kurs von
diesem carl benz das ich ja auch gekauft
und bereits schon verkauft habe einmal
um zu sehen ob ich da vielleicht
irgendwas riesiges verpasst haben das
jetzt eigentlich seitdem die letzten
drei tage nicht mehr gestiegen sagt er
nur mir so richtig krasse style aber das
hätte ich eh nicht getan ist gekommen um
mich damit auch eigentlich relativ
zufrieden damit kann man auch eigentlich
nur super happy sein den ganzen events
vor bei dem verkauf ich die ganzen
konnte jetzt erstmal gewinn bringt und
suche mir die nächsten haushalte wieder
einmal einen news nach was da so abgeht
ich habe schon zwei drei sachen gefunden
aber die gibt's alle bei dem broker ich
bin eigentlich gar nicht es ist ein
wirklich super schwer teilweise an dem
konzern zu kommen obwohl ich schon bei
so einem ort converter wenn wir konnte
ich aber gefunden ich kaufen kann und
die hier alle auf dieser plattform sowie
viele likes haben von denen wir einige
leute denken dass alles was ihr wird das
ist einmal polka dot
secrets und polka
will den namen auf jeden fall da habe
ich jetzt überall für zwischen 50 und
200 dollar eingekauft und wert im ganzen
letzten mal ein paar tage zu sehen
die woche ist vorbei kommen wir zum
resultat als aller erstes mal zum witz
von hand hier war positiv dass ich kaum
verlust gemacht hat risikomanagement
sicher und das hat geklappt ich glaube
so wie ich das gemacht abhängig maximal
im allerersten worst case verlust machen
was natürlich auf eine wochen gerechnet
langfristig auch nicht wenig ist aber
denke ich relativ wenig mit zockerei zu
tun hat und das war mir irgendwie ich
war auch kein hebel gespielt oder sowas
spaß gemacht hat der teil mit dem bitkom
handel jetzt aber nicht mit dem tisch
hat sich einmal nach arbeit an gefühlt
und war relativ wenig erfüllen aber
wurde da nicht um spaß sondern ums geld
und da habe ich das eigentlich ein
bisschen verlust gemacht etwa 1250 also
fast drei prozent ich denke aber dass
ich ungefähr bei null rausgekommen wäre
wenn die ganzen handelsgebühren nicht so
gewesen wären das heißt beim nächsten
mal sollte ich mir vielleicht ein
anderen druck heraussuchen viel
spannender und auch deutlich
risikoreicher waren da aber ewald kainz
die ich ja immer für mehrere tage
gehalten habe und sage jetzt mal blick
auf das 500 dollar 550 gemacht zehn
prozent in der woche also super stark
abziehen müssen wir da jetzt noch 25
euro gebühren die ich beim aufladen
gezahlt hat ist aber meine schuld kann
man groß lassen hätte man vermeiden
können interessant ist jetzt eigentlich
dass jeder einzelne meiner all trades
alle zumindest positiv gewesen sind man
kann aber jetzt leider noch nicht 100
prozent wissen ob das jetzt tatsächlich
an der guten strategie lag oder ob das
jetzt daran lag dass woche einfach
besonders gut für crypto allgemein war
aber ich muss auch ehrlich sagen das ist
mal ein superprofi abwechslung war in
einem dieser trading videos nicht einmal
verlust zu machen wie es mir selber
gemacht habe vielen dank noch mal an
acer den link zu dem konzept die
produkten also meinem monitor und einem
laptop findet ihr ein video beschreibung
ich werde schon bald wieder mein
nächstes gerückt ist oder spannendes
experiment machen wenn ihr mich also auf
dieser reise begleiten möchte jetzt
gerne diesen kanal und dann sehen wir
uns auch schon beim nächsten mal wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]